Ikari Warriors, America's arcade hit comes home.
And welcome to NEStalgia, a chronological exploration of every NES game released in North America.
I'm Michael Esposito.
I'm Sean.
I'm Sam.
And I'm Joe. Guys, Ikari Warriors, I know I sounded like I hyped that up, but just I gotta remind everyone
who's ever listened to any episode of Nostalgia, because it's important, because you might think
I'm crazy otherwise, I only read the back of the boxes for everything.
That's the thing in the front.
Yes, yes. The back of the box.
But we're talking about Ikari Warriors, developed by SNK, and this is our first SNK game for
the NES.
But unfortunately, they didn't handle the port that was Micronics, who's gonna do...
Oh, Micronics does a lot of bad ports.
Yeah, and they're gonna do a lot of ports, period.
But, you know, SNK is going through right now like a 40th anniversary of sorts.
They're like a really old developer, I don't think people know that.
Mm-hmm. You know, just because it hasn't been covered so much.
Yeah, 40 years. Yeah, it hasn't been covered so much.
Yeah, and all of their early games are like lost to time.
Like, they just, they cannot be found.
And then we're talking like, you know, minuscule things like Breakout and stuff like that.
Oh, yeah. They didn't, you know, it's a Breakout-like.
SNK Breakout. Yeah, SNK's style of Breakout.
But SNK is a cool company in my book.
They make all the King of Fighters games.
Yeah. And speaking of which, the two main characters of Ikari Warriors are in King of Fighters.
Wow, I gotta say, I'm looking at their picture right now.
Are you referring to the box art for Ikari Warriors?
That glorious, that glorious travesty.
And for those of you unfamiliar, we're trying something new on Nostalgia.
We did it last week with BurgerTime, but we're gonna do it again with Ikari Warriors.
We're just gonna look at the box art real quick.
Cause you gotta remember, like, that's half the experience of like, 1987.
I go to the game store, I'm buying the games.
I'm going by the covers of these boxes.
Exactly. Like, similar to how you would shop for records that way.
Like, you would look at the album art, which is weird.
Because that's not a judgment of any good album.
No, no. But here we are looking at the cover.
Any impressions just on the cover?
Yeah. This is, when I saw this, I thought of Rambrose.
Rambrose. Yeah.
Which is funny because you're obviously referencing Rambo, right?
Yeah, but they're bros there.
Yeah, but like, that's clearly what SNK was going for actually.
Yeah. It's got the headbands.
Rambo First Blood Part 2 in Japan, the title was changed to be like, Rambo Ikari something.
Oh. And like, so they took Ikari from that.
And I think Ikari kind of like, loosely translates to anger in English.
Yeah. Or something like that.
I read Fury. Fury.
Yeah. So like, you know, there's clearly like a Rambo like mood here.
And you're, you know, the environment is like you're in a jungle-esque kind of thing.
So let's talk about, let's talk about Ikari Warriors, guys.
Everybody's so quiet. Well, I'm just going to tell you, I'm just noticing on the cover for the first time here,
behind the blue headband guy, right behind his arm with the gun in it, there's another
guy firing like a beam out of his gun.
You guys see that? It's like a straight line beam.
Do you again have a different box art?
No, this is the same way we checked it.
I think it's just a stylized like, it's like a, it's like I'm shooting, but it's not
a bullet because that would be like weird to see, I guess.
I don't know. I just do.
I do like though that we have the ghosts of their, their three quarter profile right
behind them in a slightly more, a slightly more dramatic view.
It's them remembering themselves from the past, you know, it's like, it's like here they
are in the jungle, but remember when they were in training, it's like, it's crazy that
it's not, you know, you would think it's like their mothers.
You know what I think is funny?
No. They got camo pants, but they come off the plane shirtless.
Well, they're also two guys looking to take down an army.
So at this point, you know, why wear a bulletproof vest?
Yeah. You should be able to do it.
Yeah. And Joe, I just want to point out now that we're finally understanding what you're talking
about with that laser thing.
That's not a laser.
That's like, you know, when the bullet goes so fast.
It's a very like stylized version, but it goes very far for like, they just like these
neo-Nazis have like advanced technology that only they can use and stuff like that.
And yeah, I said neo-Nazis.
These, that's what these guys are in the game.
In Vietnam? They're neo-Nazis because here's the reason why.
At the end of the, towards the end of the game, like in, you know, like in the headquarters,
which or whatever, whatever have you, um, because I don't really know what it is because
it's such an abstract looking thing.
But like when you get to towards the end of the game, they have like a swastika in the,
uh, yeah. Yeah.
Well, not in the NES version, the arcade version.
Okay. Yeah.
I don't think a swastika would have ever got a Nintendo family seal of approval on it.
So yeah, they obviously would have never let that into a Nintendo game, but it's in
the arcade version.
And since there were no like changes of anything for the NES version, like there's no direct
call outs to anything different.
Unlike how, you know, Russian attack actually like changed the story a little bit for the
NES version. This one, we just have to assume that there's still neo-Nazis.
As you usually do with these changes.
And so you play as a Colonel Ralph and second Lieutenant Clark.
Uh, I, I'm not joking.
And, um, you know, you might recognize them from King of Fighters and Metal Slug six and
seven. These guys are all over the place.
I like how SNK almost does like super smash brothers, but for all types of things, it's
like, you know, everybody's coming to every game, wherever you can find them.
Here they go. So basically this is just like a commando clone though.
Yeah. But they're also not, um, Colonel Ralph and second Lieutenant Clark in the American version.
I'm pretty sure they're just Paul and Vince.
Oh, right. That's the nickname.
That's their nickname.
Okay. It's just like, I'll pull it out of a hat.
Like these have any relevance to each other.
I just feel like this is all funny.
The naming convention stuff, because then the mission of the game is still to save General
Kawasaki. Like regardless, like that does not get changed.
So whether you're Paul and Vince or Ralph and Clark, you're always trying to solve General
Kawasaki. American boys, you know, a couple of American boys, clearly American boys too, by that box
art. Those guys are like, you know, the definition of like a, a Rocky Rambo crossover.
80s Americans.
I really like Ram bros.
Yeah. Ram bros. That was very slick, Sam.
Thank you. Sean, do you want to take us through, you know, like maybe the objective of the game?
All right.
So you, um, you're just doing one of those, those commando things.
One of those normal suicide missions.
You guys against an entire army, no other army to back you up.
You, you, you, you scroll up pretty much.
And then, uh, I think, uh, the thing you have to point out for this game is it does set it
apart and then it gives you vehicles.
And I never knew while I was playing.
I mean, I did, I found out, but the first few times that I even got to a vehicle, I just
saw them as these glowing things you had to blow up.
So I would blow up my vehicles.
It's like, you guys don't read the manual.
It's so frustrating.
You're the manual guy, Sam.
Yeah. I mean, like, you know, I read it later, but anyway, it's just commando, but with vehicles.
And this is a, this is a thing though.
Commando clones, like commando was incredibly successful, came out a year earlier.
And, uh, you know, it was killing it in the arcade.
So of course every other company is going to rush out their own version.
And this is not the only version that we'll see, you know, but right now it's the second
time we're playing this kind of style of game.
And it is a little worse than like, you know, you play Kung Fu and then you play Trojan, you
know, it's like, you know, there's enough differences there and things going on.
This one is just kind of like, oh, well they added vehicles, but it's also like a lot
like less tight.
Yeah. I think I enjoyed commando.
I actually, I think I can't remember.
I think I would've put on my top five of maybe it was number five or something.
If it was, it was number five, but, um, but this was not fun.
This game. I don't know.
I kind of, I liked this game.
I think that there were, I think the controls are kind of clunky.
Like the movement, like your guy, I don't know why I have to wait for my guy to spin around
when I'm moving in a certain direction.
That's no annoying.
But when I'm in the tank, I think it's more fun.
I think if this game was like just tanks, it'd be a much better game.
Maybe you're right. So it's a vertical shooter where you're just kind of like, you know, going through enemies
and then, uh, you know, like a tank will show up and you can get in the tank and then a helicopter
will show up and get in the helicopter.
Never saw the helicopter.
Yeah. The helicopter is later into stage one, but you know, it's kind of cool that they included
these things. I think there's a lot of like nice little touches, but I, I first just want to talk about
before we even get into that, I do want to talk about the commando cloneness of this because
we already have a point in reference for us and for our listeners who have listened to
the commando episode.
So, you know, if we can just like kind of go around the room, you guys tell me like, what
didn't this game do for you that commando did it?
I didn't like commando.
Commando didn't even do anything for me.
That's a fair point too.
I don't think that I like that style of game.
I don't think for me, it comes down to whether I like the style of game or not though.
I just knew like right away, I recognized the commando similarity and I was like, okay,
I could take or leave commando.
Let's give this a shot.
I think it came down to like the tightness of the controls.
Yeah. Because it's like, everything is a lot slower.
Everything is blinking rapidly because of the sprite frame limits.
It doesn't feel one to one.
It feels like everything is clunky.
It happens like a split second later.
But at the same time, there are things in this game that I like more than commando.
Like I like that there's secret mines in this game that you can hit.
But the fact that, you know, the guys are fast, they're always going to be faster than
you and you can't really put enough space between you and them and the shooting is kind
of clunky. It detracts from it a lot.
Mm hmm. You also have a finite amount of ammo.
Yeah. I mean, you can.
The ammo can be a problem if you aren't picking up the.
No. Yeah. I'm not saying you can't get more, but I'm saying that like, you know, it's another
I don't really have. I never had a problem with them.
Sorry. They took no, they, you know, like I understand what you're saying, Sam.
Like they did take a couple of like details that again, like commando didn't like landmines
are really cool. Vehicles are cool.
Being able to walk in the water.
Yeah. But it's just lower.
I mean, so you got to strategize a little bit.
Just around in commando.
So yeah, that is kind of cool.
I think it's cool. And I think that.
Yeah. I think they made some positive steps towards it.
Sorry. I'm. You keep cutting me off.
You got it. But yeah, but we, you saw me.
I would, I was just playing commando before we got on the podcast a couple hours ago.
So, um, John Madagari warriors or command.
No, I was playing commando. Oh yeah.
Uh, because I was like, Oh, this is like, I, cause I, you were talking about how commando
is a better game. Yes, correct.
Um, and I still feel that way.
And I was like, Oh, let's see.
And commando is, it's just so much tighter.
It's such a tighter game.
But I think that there are things in this game that I like more than aspects of commando.
So I'll say that. Okay.
I felt like with the car warriors, I think it's going to kind of kind of go back to what you
guys are saying about the controls, but I felt like it was just a little more
of a frustrating experience.
Yeah. I felt like everything was dragging and like, I felt like I was trying to push forward and
everybody moves really slow.
And yeah, like, like Sam, like you said, when you turn around, he doesn't just spin around.
He has to like walk in a small circle.
Yeah. That's really annoying.
So if someone's coming up behind you, it takes you like a few seconds to turn around
and you're never going to catch them.
And it doesn't make any like real life sense at all.
Right. It seems like a weird programming bug.
And it really only happened for me though, when I like stopped on a dime and then tried
to like move in a certain direction.
I would do that little circle thing.
It wasn't like, but there's still like a half second delay when you're like changing
directions and your gun like shifts over slightly.
Like it doesn't shift when you move.
Here's my, here's my biggest issue with it.
Like just them making a Kari warrior for any S the, the thing that was cool about a Kari
warrior in the arcade was the fact that it was like a twin stick shooter.
Like you could be walking in a direction and firing in a completely different one.
Really? Yeah.
It was a completely different experience.
Like this is not, um, that was their twist on the genre.
Yeah. This is nothing like what made that game interesting.
And I don't know if, if it even needed to have been ported, if that, if they couldn't
do. Well, I mean, the answer is of course it needed to be ported because the NES is a runaway success
now. And it's like, we got to get on board with this.
The problem is, is it's a lazy port where, you know, clearly the, I mean, if you look at
the arcade version, it's, you know, Sam said when I showed it to him, it's a completely
different game. Yeah.
You know, it's really cool.
It performs really well.
It's obviously tight.
There's, um, you know, there's a lot more visual cues as to what's going on in the atmosphere
and stuff like that, but I don't want to bash the game too much.
So, you know, Sam was kind of getting into it earlier about these little details, but
I, I just really even appreciate the way the game starts.
We got a cut scene. It's a cool cut scene.
How many cut scenes have we had in NES games so far?
Yeah, there's not been many, but Commando had one, right?
I mean, sort of. Sort of.
Well, it's just the helicopter dropping you off.
Yeah. Well, then it's part of the game.
And Russian Attack has several.
Yeah. And, um, also didn't, um, Kung Fu have the save Sylvia thing?
Yeah. That was like after the first level.
It was the second level. Yeah.
That's when you get your mission.
Like, oh yeah, that's one. Yeah.
We forgot to tell you, this is what you're doing.
I like the idea that in the first level, you're just training in the dojo and then all
of a sudden it's like, you're like, wait, what?
Yeah. But I thought that, that, that, that intro cut scene thing was kind of cool.
And I think like, you know, the way that, uh, two player is implemented is like a nice
touch because Commando is just like character, you know, player one goes, they died.
Then player two goes in Ikari Warriors, even on the NES version, two players playing on the
same screen. Like that's, that's a very cool thing.
And Sam and I got an opportunity to play that and had a lot more fun with that version of
it. Yeah. I think that was a lot of fun.
I think it makes more sense for, you know, at least two people to take God and army.
Yeah. I do always think that this kind of multiplayer is better than what Commando did where you
alternate. Yeah.
I like the idea that it's a game where you're playing together.
Yeah.
But to go back to Sean talking about the, uh, the twin stick part of it, there is a, you
know, and it's a very small thing, but Sam opened my eyes to this about when you're in
the tank, you can control how you shoot.
Yes. Yeah. By, by, by, by stopping and then adjusting and then going again.
I think that's cool that they, it's, it's, it's a problem.
It's the solving of a problem, but it's not elegant.
But again, I think if it was just a tank game, it'd be more fun.
Cause I, I, when I was in the tank, I was having the most fun.
I agree, but I, I don't think I would still, I really still don't think I would like this
game very much. It changes the game too much for me.
Like, you know, if you just like for me, even like playing in the tank was like, it
was like a cool touch.
I wouldn't want to play the whole game in the tank.
I guess that's fair. I guess it's just cause the, the walking around was so, like, was so janky.
You're supposed to be an Ikari warrior.
But the only reason I feel like I agree with the tank thing is because yeah, I really didn't
like walking around.
Yeah. I felt like it controlled very poorly.
Yeah. And you're frustrated.
I guess it's just the tanks just control better.
What's everybody's thoughts on the difficulty, the difficulty of this game starts off very
difficult, but I think you can learn it pretty fast.
But then you like, you get to a point in the game where you're like, I should be done
by now. Yeah. I agree.
It is impressively long.
This, this whole game get, I mean, does there, does it tell you that you, you got through
stage one? Like it stops the game.
I could not get through stage one.
I kept thinking cause it keeps tricking you.
It keeps thinking like, Oh, here's a wall.
This is going to be the boss.
And like, Oh, I beat that stuff.
I keep going. And there's like a tank.
And I'm like, Oh, I'll beat this.
And I found one of the old cheats, which was as soon as you lose your last life, you can
just hit it. Continue by going like a, a, b, b, a, a, cause it's one of those like a, b, b, a, or something
is continue.
And I kept doing that every time I died.
And I could not even just through sheer force of will get to the end of the first level.
There was a point where I started to wonder, are there levels in this game or is this just
a really long level?
So the way that it works is, uh, you're, you're both kind of right.
Uh, there's two areas in the game total.
They are incredibly long.
I would put them in length to like a full game of super Mario brothers, you know, like,
like that's how long these, these levels are.
And so there's kind of like, you know, they call them area one and area two.
Wow. And creative.
Yeah. Area one is like, you know, kind of storming up to like, you have to go through the jungle
into the waters, take the helicopter, do all this stuff.
And then area two is more like you're at the base now and it's like really confined spaces.
And it's, it's even more difficult.
It seems like such a waste that it's so hard to get there.
Like, I feel like most of the people that get this game are never going to get there.
Sure. But I think that, that, you know, it also offers something, something different and
unique in the sense of how it handles like a level, like it's just an incredibly long
level. Yeah.
Even though I didn't get through any of that, I give them, I give them props for that.
Cause I kind of, just as you are describing that, it sounds kind of cool.
Like, Oh, I'm kind of actually traversing this environment and seeing like the progression
of like, now I'm in the swampy area, I'm in the jungle area.
It's like a point A to B thing that you can like very clearly see.
Yeah. I think it's kind of cool that like every time I got a little bit further, you know, like
when the first time I saw the helicopter, I was like, Whoa, you could do a helicopter too.
Like that was cool.
You know? So yeah, the sun says that.
So yeah. All that stuff is really cool.
And the, the, it's the little details in this game that make me like turn around on it a
little bit, but that's why, you know, I wanted to start with like the complaints first, because
I think that like, it's very easy to talk about all these nice little details that the
game does, but you have to remember like all of its shortcomings too.
Any straight thoughts
Any thoughts on this one? I wasn't sure what some of the power-ups were.
We figured out that one kills all the enemies on the screen.
Yeah, the K. What's the P?
I don't know. I don't know what the rest of them are.
But there's also an icon of a pistol.
Oh, there's the icon.
Honestly, I have no idea.
And there's some that could be rockets if you're in the tank,
and some that do. I'm not really sure.
You asked this question without knowing the answer?
Yeah, that's what questions are for.
That wasn't a straight question.
It was a straight thought. All right, here's a straight thought.
I thought that the dying animation was way too annoying.
Yeah. Oh, I'm spinning and I can't get up.
I think we're going to say the same thing.
But when you die the last time,
it's like here's 30 seconds for you to think about it
before we tell you it's a game over.
Yeah, exactly. 30 seconds where nobody's on the screen.
I mean, that's just for you to put in any code that you want.
Oh, yeah, I didn't know there was a code.
Right, but not knowing that there's a code,
that's how I felt too. I was like, can I just start over?
Do I have to hit reset?
Maybe it's to encourage people to just press buttons
to try and do something.
That's true. Maybe they'll discover it.
Maybe they'll find the code, yeah.
But I was actually going to bring up something different, Joe,
weirdly enough. I thought we were in sync.
When you're in the helicopter or the tank,
how do you get out?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. It says in the manual that you press A and then B,
which works sometimes.
But if you get shot enough that your tank is about to explode
and you do it, I felt like it worked 25% of the time.
Yeah, I died a lot.
I was almost afraid of the tank at some point
just because I'm like, I'm going to get in that death trap.
I guess it's a very realistic way to represent you
getting trapped in a burning vehicle.
Yeah, sometimes you can get out, sometimes you can't.
Also, I'm not sure if it's a glitch,
but I saw in our two-player game,
I saw Sam run over someone and they died,
and I thought that was a nice touch.
I did it twice, so I don't think it's a glitch.
I'm not sure if I took damage.
When you're in the tank, it's like you're a powerhouse.
I don't know if I took damage from that, but I don't know.
I don't care if you did. I'm saying it's nice that at least the person died, too.
Yeah, that's nice. Nice.
It just went face-to-face with a tank,
you know how annoying it would be
if they came out the other side?
Like, I'm not done with you, buddy.
A ton of damage. Tank starts on fire.
And I would say that there's some nice set pieces
throughout this game. I like those bridges.
Yeah, I think it's interesting
because it makes you think about how you're going to attack.
You know, there's people across the river from you
and there's a bridge and you're in a tank.
You can be like, all right,
I can either cross the bridge on my tank
or get out of the tank and cross the river as a person.
So hearing you guys describe it,
I'm like, wow, this sounds fun.
Yeah. But then I got to remind myself,
no, I had a terrible time with this game.
That's what I'm saying. It's tricky. But it sounds so fun.
I think it could have been a great game.
And it is a great game on the arcade version.
I highly recommend the arcade version.
It's a good game.
Like, don't get me wrong. I'm just saying that, like,
it's so easy to talk about, like,
all the cool things about this game
and then remember, but wait a minute,
the controls stink.
It's easy to die.
I barely can shoot my gun.
You know, it's, in theory,
these things work, but then they don't
when you pop in the game and turn it on.
Yeah. Exactly. It's a near miss.
Yeah. But don't worry,
because we got two more Ikari Warrior games
coming up in the NES lifespan.
We have Ikari 2, Victory Road.
Some Pokemon references.
And Ikari 3, The Rescue.
Which, don't confuse it with
the rescue operation
that you're doing in this one.
Oh, okay. Yeah, I mean, at the end of the game,
you do rescue General Kawasaki,
so it's like, I don't know why
they're saying you don't rescue him,
and, like, who knows.
But later that same day.
Thank you for neeming that out.
All right, let's get into
the Essential Games List.
All right, it's time for
And if you don't know what that is,
check the older episodes.
No, I kid. And yes, I'm reading
a prerecorded script,
only I'm not. To confuse people,
this is the...
This is how the Essential Games List works.
We just kind of go around
and we confuse people
with how we feel about this game.
We say we don't like it,
we say we do like it.
It doesn't matter in the end,
because all that really matters
is if you vote yay or nay
for the Essential Games List.
But we're not talking about
are these games essential for the NES?
We're not talking about 1987.
I'm not talking about 2017.
I'm talking about 2018.
Are these games worth playing today
when you have access
to every other game
that's ever come out?
Clearly you have time
because you're listening to the podcast.
So let's see how you guys feel about this.
Sean. All right.
I don't see as many pros
to this game as my colleagues here.
I do like that they tried
to jazz up the commando version.
I mean, sorry. They tried to jazz up
the commando-like genre
with vehicles and, you know,
tanks and helicopters are cool.
And I like the long level lengths,
but I don't like long levels
of frustrating gameplay.
And that's all I really felt
while I was playing this.
So it's a nay for me.
That's a nay for Sean.
Remember, you need two votes
to be in the Essential Games list.
Sam. I really like this game.
I had a lot of fun with it.
I didn't know that there was
the continue code that you can do,
but knowing that now
kind of boosts it on my...
Like, it makes me like it more.
You know, I think that
if I had an NES back in the day,
this is a game I would want
because you can play it with someone also,
which I think is really cool.
And it's not even you can play it...
Like, it doesn't detract
from the experience
playing with someone. It's not like you share lives
or anything. So if you play with someone who sucks,
then, you know, it's not like they're making you suck.
They're just doing a little homework,
you know, for you, and then you're just going back
to kicking butt. Yeah.
So I like this game.
I had fun with this game.
I think the controls could have been better.
But that being said,
it's not... I don't think it's essential.
But it is a game
that I really did enjoy.
All right, Joe, you're going to be
the deciding factor here.
If you vote no, it cannot be
in the Essential Games list.
Well, I think I'm going to vote no.
There you go. I think that Commando
is head and shoulders
a better game, which also wasn't in our...
I don't think anyone
voted for Commando.
Truth. But I think that this game
being so poor
with its controls
combined with,
as someone mentioned it earlier,
the fact that the enemies
kind of like are fast
and they come up on you, it's not really a good way
to avoid them. It just kind of gets...
It gets difficult
in a way that's not...
It doesn't feel like
a fair difficult
or a fun difficult,
at least. So it makes the whole experience
kind of frustrating to me.
This game is cool.
It's got a lot of
nice little set pieces.
I think in the same way
we talked about Russian Attack
having amazing
background pixel art,
this game has it
kind of like in its atmosphere
and its tone and you can tell
where you are
and I like that
you can go in the water
and play with the vehicles
and stuff like that
but then I remember
how this game plays
and I immediately
don't want to
go back to it
and I think that's crazy
that something like that
you know something like
a game that I'm interested
in playing until I actually
start playing it and I'm like
oh right I don't want to touch this.
Go play the arcade version
it's so much better
even today
it's not like
you know still head and shoulders
above the rest but I think it's worth a try
so definitely go try
and seek out that arcade version
but for the NES version
it's a bad port
and hopefully Micronics can try
a little harder in the future
but I think we all know
where that's going
so I'm a no
everybody's a no
that's four no's
so this thing is not
getting on the essential games list.
One thing I want to add
that this game
it seems like
the kind of game
that you would play
with your parents.
Really? What?
I didn't know if you were
going to get punked in me
No no no I feel like
it's like oh like
I feel like my dad doesn't like
video games but I feel like
he would like this Oh my dad just got back
from Vietnam Yeah
Oh that's a good point
that's the 80s
I don't know like this is a pretty
like video game
video game when I think of
video games of
the 80s I could see this
in my head like what makes you
think it's any different
because it's like I feel like
if I was like a dad
and my son's like
or my son or daughter
you know is like playing
That's what NES
golf is for
Yeah That's a dad game
It's like oh there's these
two shirtless dudes
fighting people like yeah
we'll give that a shot
and then you die who cares
they keep playing and you're like
alright you're doing great
and you go and you have a beer
I guess I can see
what you mean it's like
it's easily accessible
like your goal is shoot the bad guy
Yeah yeah you know
and you're like
a shirtless guy
in a headband I don't know
I just I saw
some kind of parent
playing with a kid for this game specifically
Yeah yeah Let me just throw it out there
that you know and I'll probably throw
one of these in the show notes
but this is at a time
where like video games are feared
by like some parents
in the sense that like
my kid's playing these games
where he shoots people
he's gonna grow up and be a murderer
you know and then like
the news would like
do coverage on this
that like the local news
and this will continue
for decades the local news
will like come to like people's houses
and she'll be like yeah they just
always play the Nintendo
and then it shows like them playing Genesis
you know it's like this is just like
a misinformed time
for parents so like I'm sure there were
a couple cool dads
and moms out there
who like already played video games
and now wanted to
like play them with their kids
or something but like
that's like that's really not
happening for the most part
I see it as that
well I'm glad
you heard it here guys
Ikari Warriors family fun
but not essential
and one last
little thing I want to throw
and one other
sorry sorry
but I don't think
that I don't think
we've done this yet but I cannot
imagine
if there is a port
that ever gets on
the essential games list
that is somehow
the worst version
of a like a much
better like arcade
game or game
on a different on a different console
like I just don't think
that we should do that
it just doesn't really make sense
if you think about how we're talking
about not just
the NES we're talking about
every game
that you have available to you
and it's like well you would have a better version
available to you
that's a good point
however there are
some things that
like the NES version
changes enough
that it's yeah I mean
if but I think
like if it's
on an apples to apples
basis and it's
just that much
worse it would have to
be very good it would have to
be still very good
I don't know yes I agree
I think the only
thing the NES would offer to
something like that is that you have
it in your home yeah keep in mind
yeah arcade is
like you know it's very hard to
I always say
you know play these games
but you're good
good luck tracking them down
like you know any verse system
game is near
impossible to find
any like
Akari Warriors you're not going
to just find that
at like you know the nearest arcade
you're going to have to seek it out
major metro too
right so you know
it's not it's easier said than done
and I do agree that like you know
the NES has at least
the fact that you know you can
just go on eBay and find it
and not spend $700 on the cabinet
so that's all the time
we have for this episode of Nostalgia
join us next time
for Castlevania
Castlevania
and be sure to play it yourself
if you can
you like to play
Castlevania
okay thank you for that
I'm sure somebody
enjoyed that yeah I enjoyed it
oh good okay
there's the fan again
speaking of enjoying
stuff if you're
enjoying the podcast
why not hit that
subscribe button
and continue to listen to us
we publish episodes
every Friday
and we will continue
to do so as long as there
are NES games
to be played in chronological order
wait do we have any more
what do we have any more
we have we have a few more
okay yeah in North America
yeah that's what
I was gonna say they have to be
in North America yeah
unfortunately the Japanese ones
and maybe we'll do a special
sometime but you know
we do have special stuff
yeah we do have
special stuff on the website
that's www.nostalgiacast.com
and on the website
you can find all the previous shows
download links
to the episodes in case you just
want to have like offline
versions of them
we also have
show notes
and detailed
thoughts and articles
who knows what you're gonna
find on there it's a lot of fun
we also got a Twitter
and Twitch
YouTube Facebook all that stuff
so definitely check that stuff out
and that's about it
so I'm Michael Esposito
you can find me on
at Esposito Film
on Twitter and I'll talk to you soon
p p p p
p! This is W.I.I.
This is W.I.I. This is W.I.I.
This is W.I.I. This is W.I.I. This is W.I.I. This is W.I.I. This is W.I.I. This is W.I.I. This is W.I.I. This is W.I.I. This is W.I. This is W.I. This W.I. This W.I. This W.I. This W.I. This W.I. This W.I. This W.I. This W.I. This W.I. This W.I. This W.I. This W.I. This W.I. This W.I. This W.I. This W.I. This W.I. This W.I. This W.I. This W.I. This W.I. This W